HAVE THE BEST EVENING.
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
CRITICAL MULTITRILLION DOLLAR
STIMULUS PACKAGE INSTALLED ON
THE U.S. SENATE.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHEN A VOTE WILL
TAKE PLACE.
THEY ARE OR IN THE HOUSE EITHER.
YOU KNOW, IN A TIME OF GREAT
URGENCY FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY,
WE HAVE SEEN, LET’S START WITH
THE BEST IN PEOPLE.
LOOK AT ALL THESE BUSINESSES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SCREEN.
ALL OF THEM ON YOUR SCREEN HAVE
STEPPED UP, HUGE, MASSIVE,
INCREDIBLE HEROIC WAYS TO HELP
THEIR FELLOW AMERICANS.
PRODUCING VENTILATORS AND MASKS.
THE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT THAT IS
NEEDED FOR THE BEST DOCTORS,
BEST NURSES, BEST MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD THAT ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES HELPING AMERICANS THAT ARE
SICK, PUTTING THEMSELVES IN
HARM’S WAY.
WE CANNOT THANK THEM ENOUGH FOR
THEIR SERVICE AND THEIR COURAGE.
THESE COMPANIES HAVE ALL STEPPED
UP.
THIS PRESIDENT AND HIS
TASK FORCE, THEY ARE MAKING
LITERALLY LIFE-SAVING CHOICES
NOW.
REWRITING THE BOOK SO THAT IT
WILL FOREVER TRANSFORM HOW WE
DEAL WITH FUTURE PANDEMICS.
TRAVELTRAVEL BANS, QUARANTINES,
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS,
DRIVE-THRU TESTING, SOON WE WILL
HAVE HOME TESTING.
TELEMEDICINE, ALL OF IT IS THE
FUTURE.
OFF LABEL USE AND ELIMINATION OF
TWO GHANAIAN RULES BY THE FDA
FOR COMPASSIONATE USE, THE RIGHT
TO TRY, WHY NOT?
VACCINE TRIALS IN RECORD TIME.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
YOU ARE WATCHING HISTORY UNFOLD.
THIS IS TRANSFORMATIONAL, LIVES
WILL BE SAVED AND LIVES ARE
CHANGING.
BUT IN THE MIDST OF TRAGEDY AND
TRIUMPH
two Ghanaian rules by the FDA
AND AMAZING ACHIEVEMENTS, LOOK
AT THE TRAVEL BAN.
LET’S START.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS FROM CONTRACTING THE
VIRUS, SAVE THEM.
BOUGHT US VALUABLE TIME AND SAVE
LIVES.
THIS IS AMERICA AT ITS FINEST.
ALL OF THESE THINGS TO PROTECT
AND SAVE LIVES FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, LET ME SAY, HE IS
NOW, HE’S BEEN WAITING FOR A
WEEK FOR A BELL.
WHAT WE’VE BEEN WATCHING LAST
WEEKEND ALL THIS WEEK IN THE
WASHINGTON SWAMP, THAT IS
AMERICA AT ITS WORST IN D.C.
UNFORTUNATELY DURING TOUGH
TIMES, WE DO SEE PEOPLE AT THEIR
WORST.
WE SEE PEOPLE PRICE GOUGING FOR
NEEDED SUPPLIES, MEDICAL
SUPPLIES, MASKS.
THEN YOU SEE THE ORDERS AND
PEOPLE FIGHTING OVER TOILET
PAPER.
IT’S INSANE.
THANKFULLY THAT IS NOT THE
MAJORITY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE SWAMP IS BEYOND REPULSIVE.
JUST AS THEY HAVE FOR THREE LONG
PLUS YEARS, RADICAL SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS, DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE HURTING THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE WATCHED DAY AFTER DAY
AFTER DAY DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
LITERALLY EXPLOITING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
THEY HAVE BEEN HOLDING BACK WHAT
IS DESPERATELY NEEDED MONEY FOR
AMERICAN WORKERS, AMERICAN SMALL
BUSINESSES.
BIG INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE BEEN
BASICALLY SHUT DOWN AS A RESULT
OF THIS VIRUS.
SO THEY CAN JAM DOWN THE THROATS
OF YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT
IS THERE A DISASTROUS SOCIALIST
AGENDA AND OF COURSE PART OF THE
INSANE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THEY HAVE HELD DESPERATELY
NEEDED RELIEF MONEY HOSTAGE.
I SAUCE SUSAN COLLINS OF
MAINE, LITERALLY WHERE IS YOUR
URGENCY?
I HAVE NEVER, EVER IN MY LIFE
SEEN MITCH McCONNELL THAT
ANGRY EITHER.
AMERICAN WORKERS, THEY NEEDED
HELP LAST WEEK.
THEY NEED HELP NOW.
SMALL BUSINESSES NEED HELP NOW.
BIG BUSINESSES, WIPED OUT BY THE
CORONAVIRUS, THEY NEED HELP NOW
SO THEY CAN HELP THEIR EMPLOYEES
NOW.
THEY NEEDED THAT LAST WEEK.
HERE WE ARE A WEEK LATER STILL
DEALING WITH DEMOCRATIC B.S.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
THEY HAVE BEEN LITERALLY
TREATING THIS EMERGENCY STIMULUS
PLAN LIKE A COOKIE JAR.
THEY ARE PRICE GOUGING YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I WARNED YOU THIS WAS COMING.
THEY NEEDED TO PASS A CLEAN
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF BILL.
WHY WASTE A GOOD CRISIS, RIGHT,
RAHM EMANUEL?
TO DO THE THINGS YOU KNOW YOU
WOULD NEVER OTHERWISE GET DONE.
YEAH, PELOSI.
BIPARTISAN PLAN OVER WHAT?
A GREEN NEW DEAL?
AND CARBON FOOTPRINTS AND THEIR
WISH LIST OF UNRELATED DEMANDS,
TAX CREDITS FOR WINDMILLS AND
SOLAR PANELS AND NEW
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS FOR
THE AIRLINES.
YEAH, AS IF THEY ARE NOT
SUFFERING AND AFTER LET’S TAKE
THEM IN THE HEAD WHILE THEY ARE
DOWN ON THE GROUND BLEEDING
PROFUSELY AND THEY HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED.
THEN THEY ADD PROJECTIONS.
GLAD TO BRING IN THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT ISSUE.
GOT TO GIVE NEW POWERS TO UNION
BOSSES AND ON AND ON.
AS IT STANDS NOW, ONLY SOME OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PORK HAS MADE IT
INTO THIS BILL BUT A TENTATIVE
DEMOCRATIC PRICE GOUGING
REMAINS.
LOOK AT THIS.
AT $150 MILLION FOR THE NATIONAL
ENDOWMENT FOR THE ARTS AND THE
ENDOWMENT FOR THE HUMANITIES.
OH, NOW, THEY WANTED 600 MILLION
ORIGINALLY.
THAT’S WHAT THEY WERE FIGHTING
FOR.
THAT’S WHAT THE DELAY HAS BEEN
ABOUT.
THERE’S ALSO A PHOTO,
$50 MILLION FOR THE INSTITUTE OF
MUSEUM AND LIBRARY SERVICES.
OKAY IF WE NEED MONEY TO HELP
THEIR EMPLOYEES, THAT’S SEPARATE
AND APART.
THAT’S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
75 MILLION FOR THE CORPORATION
FOR PUBLIC BROADCASTING.
75 MILLION FOR PBS, OH, AND I
THINK MPR IS INCLUDED.
NPR, ONE OF THEIR STATIONS
ANNOUNCED THEY WEREN’T GOING TO
TAKE THE DAILY BRIEFINGS BUT
THEY GET 75 MILLION BUCKS.
THE CHERRY ON TOP OF THE WISH
LIST, 25 MILLION FOR THE KENNEDY
PERFORMING ARTS CENTER.
PROTECT THE EMPLOYEES IF THEY
ARE OUT OF WORK.
THIS MONEY, TOTAL B.S.
SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING HERE?
YOU ARE WATCHING THE
EXPLOITATION BY THE DEMOCRATS
HOLDING AMERICANS IN NEED
HOSTAGE OVER THIS GARBAGE.
ALL IN ORDER TO GET A BIG PAYDAY
FOR THEIR CLOSE FRIENDS AND
UNION BUDDIES.
THEY KNOW REPUBLICANS.
THEY HAVE A SENSE OF URGENCY.
THEY ARE THE ADULTS IN THE ROOM.
THEY HAVE BEEN SAYING WE NEED TO
GET THIS HELP TO THE AMERICAN
WORKER.
BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN TROUBLE.
THE DEMOCRATS LITERALLY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF WHAT IS AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK MOMENT.
NOW IF YOU ARE I EVER DID THIS
WE MIGHT EVEN BE ARRESTED FOR
THEFT OR LOOTING OR PRICE
GOUGING.
PROBABLY LOCKED UP AND CHARGED
WITH LARCENY.
NOT IF YOU’RE A DEMOCRATIC
MEMBER OF THE U.S. CONGRESS.
GUESS WHAT.
IT GETS WORSE.
THE BILL IS CURRENTLY STALLED.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF A PROVISION THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY PAY WORKERS IN
MANY INSTANCES MORE MONEY THAN
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE MAKE ON
THEIR JOBS IF THEY GO ON
UNEMPLOYMENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, MORE MONEY,
UNEMPLOYED THAN IF THEY WERE
EMPLOYED AS THEY CURRENTLY HAVE
BEEN.
AN IDIOTIC IDEA.
EVERY REASONABLE AMERICAN
UNDERSTANDS WE NEED TO HELP OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS.
HOW ABOUT WE JUST KEEP THEM
HOLE?
WHATEVER YOU HAVE BEEN MAKING,
YOU’RE OUT OF WORK, THROUGH NO
FAULT OF YOUR OWN, WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE YOU MAKE
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY SHOULD PAY
HER MORTGAGE, RENT, CAR PAYMENT,
FOOD, GROCERIES, PHARMACY.
THIS IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
IT’S NOT FAIR TO THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS WHO ARE ALL IN.
AMERICA IS WILLING TO HELP OUT
THEIR FELLOW AMERICANS.
MAKE THEM WHOLE DURING THIS
BRIEF PERIOD OF TIME.
THOSE THAT DESERVE THE HELP
DESERVE HELP, PERIOD.
NO BOLSHEVIK BERNIE SANDERS FOR
ME TO STOP THE WHOLE BILL IF
THIS LANGUAGE IS REMOVED.
MORE DELAYS FOR THOSE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN WAITING AND
WAITING AND WAITING AND
DESPERATELY DESERVE OUR HELP.
SO LET’S BE CLEAR.
HERE’S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN BLOCKING.
THEY’VE BEEN BLOCKING A RELIEF
BILL FOR AMERICAN WORKERS.
PBS, NPR?
THE KENNEDY PERFORMING ARTS
CENTER?
SO THEY CAN GET BIG PAYDAY AND
BOLSHEVIK BERNIE AND GET HIS
SOCIALIST WISH LIST COMPLETED.
$1200 DIRECT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
DIRECT PAYMENTS TO AMERICANS.
BUSINESS LOANS.
500 BILLION FOR DISTRESSED
COMPANIES.
ANOTHER 150 BILLION FOR
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS.
THEY ARE ALL WAITING.
THIS COULD HAVE AND SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PASSED A WEEK AGO AND AS WE
SPEAK, THE PRESIDENT IS READY TO
SIGN THE BILL IMMEDIATELY.
HE HAS BEEN FOR DAYS.
THE PRESIDENT DOESN’T WRITE THE
BILLS IN CONGRESS.
IN FAIRNESS TO HIM, HE SPENT A
LITTLE BIT BUSY TRYING TO SAVE
THE LIVES OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND ALL HANDS ON DECK HEALTH
PANDEMIC.
HE’S DONE MORE THAN ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT IN HISTORY TO SAVE
LIVES DURING A PANDEMIC.
NOBODY HAS EVER RESPONDED THIS
WAY IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THIS IS EVEN A NEW LOW FOR THE
SWAMP IN D.C., IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT JUST REEKS OF SWAMP
CORRUPTION.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES.
THEY WON’T BEAT.
THEY WILL BE PATTING THEMSELVES
ON THE BACK, TELLING TIBBETT HOW
GREAT THEY ARE.
THEY ARE NOT.
WITH THESE RADICAL SOCIALISTS
ARE DOING IS BEYOND THE PALE.
FRANKLY TONIGHT WHAT YOU BEEN
WATCHING AND WE ARE STILL
WATCHING IS A NATIONAL DISGRACE.
IT’S UNFORGIVABLE.
IF YOU ARE SITTING HOME TONIGHT
WORRIED ABOUT HOW YOU’RE GOING
TO PAY YOUR RENT, YOUR MORTGAGE,
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE, PAY HER
CAR LOAN, JUST KNOW THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CARES MORE
ABOUT NPR, PBS, THE NATIONAL
ENDOWMENT FOR THE ARTS AND THEY
THAN ANY OF YOU.
OTHERWISE YOUR MONEY BY NOW.
THIS BILL WILL PASS.
I GUESS ULTIMATELY.
THE REPUBLICANS TRYING TO GET
THE MONEY TO WORKERS.
THEY HAVE TO GIVE THIS GARBAGE
TO THE DEMOCRATS.
SO AMERICAN WORKERS AND SMALL
BUSINESS, LARGE BUSINESSES CAN
GET THE AID WE HAVE BEEN
DESPERATELY WANTING TO GIVE TO
THEM.
MARK MY WORDS.
MARK MY WORDS TONIGHT.